the Joe Rogan experience we were
watching a where of course we were
watching home alone - the other day the
one where he's lost in New York and
there's this scene where have you seen
this where he's walking through the
hotel he's you know he gets this fancy
of Delhi as his dad's credit card and
he's like lost in the hotel for a second
he's like hey excuse me sir do you know
where this is and it's Trump it stands
up and it's just Trump way back it's so
funny and Trump turns around all creepy
he looks at his butt oh no I know he's
looking at I'm like it's a little boy
right everybody do this movie it's a
really funny movie home alone too is
like really well right now is my mind
was blown watching the whole thing such
a great Christmas movie and there's so
many great actors and it's an insane
lineup Rob Schneider is actually
hilarious in this one those are classic
yeah he's mad we're kids those were huge
they put it together so well like I'm
looking at it now I guess it's the
writer in me or the LA guy like I'm
looking at movies differently now and
I'm like this is so beautiful how they
made this coincidence happen because you
do anything else first of all they look
like horrible parents no movie too
terrible they get no [ __ ] playing
with other son like who are you right so
they really had to make this one work
out and they do such a great job with it
he's a replacement batteries a guy that
they're running of course still this
late family that can never have their
[ __ ] together and he's chasing the guy
and it makes sense cuz he runs into the
lady taking tickets you expect when they
took physical tickets and he runs into
the ladies chasing the guy that looks
like his dad and the tickets go
everywhere so it makes sense that he
doesn't have a seat and it makes sense
it and they went he went to the wrong
gate following the wrong guy like
everything makes sense it's beautiful
that they can make comedies that way
back then like could rationalize a
family being in a different place than
their little child wonderful could do
that movie today people would just shame
you all right never get a chance yeah
just announced today they're remaking
not remaking they're making a new I hope
it I guess it's a reboot for a Disney
Plus of home alone a whole new story
whole new characters you know it should
be it's Macaulay Culkin as a 40 year old
man trying to figure out what the [ __ ]
happened to him they put him on these
movies when he
little baby he's a cool guy very nice
guy I had him in here on the podcast I
really enjoyed talking to very smart
just a very interesting little fella but
you know it ain't good for anybody to do
that to their kids make your kids that
[ __ ] famous remember how famous
Macaulay Culkin was oh my god he was
Giganta and when you're a little boy and
you're growing up gigant I like that and
then all sudden you're this 40-year old
man where he is now really nice guy
really cool really fun to talk to
recommended by Kevin Smith Kevin Smith
told me I have to have him on you'll say
- you gotta talk to the guy he's great
he really is really interesting cat just
travels around the world doesn't ever
the [ __ ] he wants has a shitload of
money right from all the home alone
movies but doesn't spend it just not
going crazy he's not buying Ferraris
right he just does whatever he wants
he's nothing like his character in the
Marvel belly south well he's a grown-up
he's a grown-up man of leisure but I
think out of all the people that I've
ever met that are famous at a you know
child's age he might be the best at it
because I think it's an impossible task
I really do and I think in the only way
it really works if you can handle Fame
is if you have you you've developed
character over your life and become an
adult and and we're nothing and
understand hard work and understand the
fortune that you have to be famous or to
be successful in show business but if
you grow up like that man all your
signals are all crossed wrong all your
wires are all [ __ ] up you grow up
thinking that you're SuperDuper
important for no reason with no work at
all and that you can literally get
whatever you want don't have people get
it for you
anytime you want all the time like
Justin Bieber how how how is he not
gonna be crazy
how is he not gonna be crazy tell me he
I think he's handling it incredibly the
idea that you gonna hold him to the same
standards as this other kid who's also
24 whose dad is a football coach at the
high school and his mom is a math
teacher and they're really in tight with
their community
and he grew up going to scout camps and
you know he plays football he plays
baseball and he's got a bunch of friends
he grew up with and they're all normal
and he's had a girlfriend for the past
two years but he doesn't know if he
should make it serious when he goes to
college and come on come on man yeah
he's a whole different different kind of
person man yeah a kid who went to a
normal high school and went to a normal
college and then became 22 versus poor
[ __ ] him right pulled out of school
so you don't have real like knowledge of
history can probably barely read Justin
Bieber's what 23 or something probably
worth hundreds of millions of dollars
and probably had girls just launch
themselves at him from the time that he
was a little boy in a way that no one
who's not Justin Bieber's ever gonna
understand and yet we're like look at
this guy
such a loser yeah get your [ __ ] together
loser instead of looking at it like a
child abuse case right it's almost like
child abuse I mean the best kind of
abuse ever like cry me a river you got a
couple hundred million dollars out of a
biotherapy bro yeah but but I don't know
if a therapist would work
the thing about something like that is
that's the kind of development I sound
like a psychologist someone barely went
to school but the kind of developmental
damage that happens when you don't have
to go through all the normal stuff that
everyone else did like here's the thing
about like one thing that UFC fighters
and comics a lot of us have in common is
that we had [ __ ] lives growing up you
were probably bullied you felt insecure
I got into martial arts 100% so scared
people gonna beat me up
hundred percent wasn't a big kid and I
didn't know a lot of keep people in the
high school where I went to I just moved
there and I was a [ __ ] I am I'm so
scared all the time I got to do
something and I went to an easy high
school like Newton South was an easy
high school don't they bust these
inner-city kids though that would [ __ ]
you up
there was some tough people there but
the point is that like if you don't have
a motivation to work
whether it's to become a stand-up
whether it's to become a martial artist
or what anything that you like
you like I got to get out of here I got
to do something different I got to make
something happen you got to go through
[ __ ]
for that feeling to sort of emerge with
enough horsepower to get you some
momentum it's I can't imagine who I
would be if I was famous when I was six
I'd be such a mess that's I mean the
drugs they have this they have this they
just can't get they can't pump the
serotonin out of their brain fast enough
you know so they a lot of you know
that's why so many of these people chase
these dragons well they also get really
depressed when they don't have continual
constant success like a lot of kids that
experience like an early peak and you
know everybody loves them and they're
super used to it and everybody's kissing
their ass and then it drops off and
they're like what what do you mean drops
off and they get crazy because they want
to get it back I don't get my relevance
I don't get my this how do I get my that
[Applause]